now Yale University professor is
teaching students around the world how
science can help them lead a happier
life Laurie Santos started the class
psychology and the good life in January
nearly 1/4 of Yale's undergraduates
enrolled making it the most popular
course in the school's more than three
hundred year history
now her teachings are spreading well
beyond campus more than 138 thousand
people around the world have registered
for the online version of the class
professor Santos joins us for a crash
course on happiness we've been so
excited to talk to you all morning
so excited to get happy be happy go so
what just what's the first step
yeah so the first step is really to
realize that some of our intuitions
about what we need to do to be happy are
just wrong in the class I talk to
students about how our minds lie to us
they tell us what if I want to be happy
I need to change my circumstances I need
a new job or I need a better salary or I
need to move but really what the
research says is that if you want to
become happier you just need to change
your mindset your circumstances are fine
it's kind of how you react to them so
you call these rewire Mint's right how
do you do that how do you rewire yeah
well we call them requirements because
they're just different tips that you can
do to rewire the way you think about
things rewire the way you behave I mean
one simple one is just to make more
social connections with other people
what the research suggests is that very
happy people spend lots of time with
people the people they like their loved
ones but also they just talk to the
barista you know so that's just a simple
requirement we suggest to students it's
like how much time are you spending with
other people can you actually spend more
time with us when you say social
connections you mean physical
connections right not social media
connection yes and that's such an
important point I think there's this
real opportunity cost you know we're
scrolling through our Instagram feed and
we feel like that's social but it's not
we just need one on one real live
conversation with another human so it
seems like you're suggesting two things
one is the old you know nothing is but
thinking makes it so
which is just change the way you think
about things the other is change your
actions make these connections with
people and and develop community in a in
an actual way not in the superficial
social media way that's right and this
is this
nomination is kind of changing how you
think and how you act is part of so many
of the different tips another tip we
talk to students about is to take time
for gratitude which is partly a thinking
thing it's like don't focus on the
hassles focus on the blessings in life
and this one is really hard for me you
know when I go out for a glass of wine
with a girlfriend I don't want to talk
about all the wonderful things right
life I want to complain but but it turns
out that that's another spot where our
minds lying to us it's just wrong and
there are some gratitude tricks like the
one you before you go to sleep at night
the three things you're grateful for
that has shown hasn't that shown actual
but more in tests beneficial data on
that yeah that's the amazing thing is
when you do the science on it what you
find are these really simple practices
can change things another activity with
gratitude is what's called a gratitude
letter where you sit down for like you
know 15 minutes and write a letter to
somebody who you're really thankful to
have had in your life but you haven't
had a chance to thank them that act can
boost up well-being ratings a month
later so a simple 15 minute thing that
you can do just thank someone can bump
up your happiness for a whole month
I saw something flash on the screen
random acts of kindness what does that
mean and how does that benefit our own
happiness this is another one where our
minds lied to us you know if I'm having
a bad day I think I'm gonna treat myself
you know I'm gonna go out for a manicure
I'm gonna get a nice mimimi
yes but it turns out that helping others
actually bumps up our happiness more
than we think there's lovely research by
the psychologist Liz done that shows
that the simple act of spending $20 on
someone or spending $5 on someone can
boost up your happiness for a whole day
and can make you happier than spending
that money on yourself what kind of
homework did you assign your students in
this class well we know that it's it's
tough to put these things into practice
so I gave students the homework of doing
these exact practices that I'm
mentioning not for a grade because we
wouldn't grade them at Yale on you know
being nice to someone but just it's in
the syllabus and you have to do it and
so they were simple things like
experience gratitude talk to someone and
other simple healthy habits like sleep
and exercise well professor will we're
very grateful that you have been here
and thank you very much happier having
had this conversation it's already
working thanks so much